I hope you guys had a wonderful conference so far.
Have a great day ahead.
Welcome to the AV Capsit Engineering 4 session.
I'm Saurav Chaudhary.
Before we begin, I have a couple of quick reminders,
which you've probably heard before.
As a reminder, the use of flash photography and filming
is prohibited during the session.
I'm supposed to tell you that there is Wi-Fi and there
is an app, but if you have not used it, that's why you're
not going to use it now, so it should be good.
And your feedback is incredibly useful to us.
I'll circle back on that topic at the end.
So without further ado, it's my pleasure
to welcome Tyler Moyr from Voyager Therapeutics.
He's going to talk to us about the directed evolution
of muscular and neuromuscular capsid variants
in both mice and non-human primates.
Tyler, take it away.
All right, thank you for that introduction,
and thank you to the organizers for allowing me
to share this work with you all that we've
been working on for the past few years.
What I'm going to talk about today
is actually probably a bit of a different direction
for Voyager Therapeutics.
If you're familiar with our work, you know,
of our work more in the CNS and gene therapy space
for neurodegenerative disorders.
But today, I'm going to talk about some work
that we've done developing novel capsids for muscular
and neuromuscular indications.
So at Voyager, we've developed the tracer platform,
which is an RNA-based AAV capsid evolution platform
that allows us to evolve and engineer capsids
with tissue-specific targeting for maximal gene delivery
to a given tissue of interest.
And of course, as I mentioned,
we first applied the tracer platform
to engineer transformative BBB penetrant AAV vectors
for CNS-specific disorders.
And on that note, I hope you all got the opportunity
to hear our chief scientific officer,
Todd Carter, present this past Wednesday morning
about the development of VY-1706.
And that is our gene therapy product
for Alzheimer's disease.
It's a tau knockdown.
We're really excited about the three-month GLP
tox data that he presented,
and we're hoping to take that into the clinic later this year.
So please stay tuned.
But of course, outside of the CNS and beyond the BBB,
there is need across many therapeutic areas
for better, safer, stronger AAV capsids
for gene therapy programs.
And that's what I'm going to talk about here momentarily.
So given that this is capsid engineering four,
by now I presume many of you are familiar with the
and overall capsid engineering platform overview.
So for us, instead of processing brain tissue,
we can easily just choose another tissue of interest.
And now we've begun working in skeletal muscle
and cardiac muscle.
So we did this over the past few years.
We launched a number of campaigns
to identify muscle-specific capsids.
And here I'm showing the results of one of our campaigns.
We're looking at the enrichment of a number of pooled variants
in a synomologous macaque muscle and mouse muscle
relative to AAV9.
And we were able to uncover a host of variants
that showed enrichment in the muscles
in both of those species.
And in fact, in the monkeys,
some that were improved upon a known monkey benchmark
muscle capsid.
So we chose a collection of these to begin evaluating
and we were able to quite easily evaluate a lot of them
in mice, so that's where I'll start.
So relative to AAV9, we examined a bunch of capsids
and when we looked at whole body and vivo imaging,
we had a number of capsids that had substantial
muscle targeting globally in muscles relative to AAV9.
And they were on the order or in some cases,
better than the benchmark capsid that we evaluated.
So we chose one of these capsids.
We denote it VCAP290 and we'll take a closer look
at that one.
So when we looked at VCAP290's ability
to deliver a transgene here to the muscles,
what we saw was just really a substantial increase
over AAV9 in all muscle tissues that we examined.
And again, sort of at the level or better
than a benchmark capsid.
And that was confirmed when we did more bioanalytics on it.
In mice, VCAP290 had about 100-fold improvement
in expression over AAV9.
In heart tissue, it was about 10-fold improved.
And we want to note that in liver,
we actually did see a mild detargeting
in terms of biodistribution to the liver.
Now, when we first looked at these muscle capsids,
we were at least these images, these histology images,
we were really struck and it looked at this global view
like we were really hitting every single muscle fiber
and at this dose.
And we confirmed that when we zoomed in a bit
in skeletal muscle at this dose of 2.5 E13 VGs per KIG,
which therapeutically would say is a low dose
compared to what's being used in the clinic,
we were hitting every muscle fiber.
So we decided to take that even lower
and we did a five-fold reduction in dose
down to five E12 VGs per KIG.
And again, we were able to hit 100%
of skeletal muscle fibers,
although we are seeing more variation
in on a fiber-by-fiber basis.
So at this point, I'm gonna switch over to our evaluation
of VCAP290 in cinemulgus macaques
and we switched trans genes here
and we go into what we presented a few years ago
as what we call sort of our multi-tag system.
This is our ability to take a number of capsids of interest.
In this case, we're gonna look at AEV9,
a primate benchmark muscle capsid and VCAP290
and we put them head-to-head in the exact same macaques.
Each capsid is dosed pretty low at four E12 VGs per KIG
and each is packaged with a histone trans gene,
each with a unique epitope tag
so that we can differentiate the capsids
based on in histology or bioanalytics.
And another note before I show the data
is that with a histone trans gene,
we aren't gonna see that fiber-wide staining
like we saw in the mouse with the cytosolic protein.
You're just gonna see targeting in the nuclei
that are squeezed up against the cell membrane there
in the muscle fibers.
But nevertheless, we can still quantify
the targeting to the muscle tissue
and in the macaque quadriceps,
we were able to see about 30% of nuclei being targeted
by VCAP290 as opposed to about 6% in AEV9.
And in terms of expression,
we saw about 25-fold increase
in trans gene expression relative to AEV9,
both of those metrics exceeding the benchmark capsid
that we evaluated.
When we look at heart,
we saw a similar thing where VCAP290
was hitting about 20% of nuclei in the heart
at this dose of 40-12
and that led to about a 13-fold increase
in expression relative to AEV9.
We also evaluated some peripheral tissues.
So in the DRGs, we noted a mild detargeting
with VCAP290 relative to AEV9,
but in the liver, we actually did see an increase
in targeting, but we really saw that as an opportunity
to continue to develop VCAP290
and push it into a second generation of evolution.
So we performed an evolution scheme with VCAP290
and we really focused choosing capsids to move forward with
that had increased expression in muscle tissue in monkeys,
which I'm showing here, but also mouse as well,
but detargeting of those peripheral tissues like the liver.
We're well underway with evaluating a number of these.
We have some exciting data thus far
and we hope to share that in the future.
But I'm gonna switch gears just a little bit
and talk about neuromuscular capsids.
And the inspiration for our work here is that
we took a look and we have done a lot of work
in the CNS space and we've developed some great capsids
that we're excited about like VCAP Gen2.
And I just described our work that we are now developing
muscle capsids like VCAP290.
But of course, in between these two ideas,
there's a therapeutic need for neuromuscular disorders
where you want capsids that have broad CNS transduction
as well as enhanced muscle tropism.
So we set out to evolve or engineer capsids
that are capable of this.
And I'm gonna share results of two separate capsids today.
These are VCAP336 and 337.
So VCAP336 is really just gonna be our first
sort of proof of concept in mouse.
And then 337 is the capsid that we evaluate in primates.
So I'll start with VCAP336.
So we're gonna compare it in the benchmark muscle mouse
capsid as well as VCAP Gen2 our own muscle capsid
or brain capsid.
And we can see that the benchmark capsid
when you look at skeletal muscle or heart tissue,
you get really strong targeting.
Not so much in the motor cortex that are in the brain.
VCAP Gen2 of course has the exact opposite phenotype
where we don't see much targeting in muscles,
but certainly in the motor cortex
we see quite a strong tropism.
And of course the question is,
do we get a best of both worlds capsid
where we combine those phenotypes?
And in mice that's what we saw.
With VCAP336 we were able to successfully increase
the targeting in the skeletal muscle and heart,
certainly relative to the baseline
of where the brain capsid was.
And in the cortex we still have a really strong targeting.
You can see there in the histology,
although we note that in terms of expression in the brain
we did take a little bit of a hit.
But nevertheless I think this validates our approach
that we are in fact getting a best of both worlds capsid
that we can target both of these tissues simultaneously
with one product.
And interestingly in the liver,
we noted that VCAP336 took on the liver phenotype
more so of our CNS capsids, which are quite liver detargeted.
So switching over to monkeys,
we're gonna revisit that multi-tag system
that I described where we do a head-to-head evaluation
in the same primates of various capsids.
So here we're using AAV9, a benchmark muscle capsid,
and our neuromuscular capsid VCAP337.
So in terms of the quadriceps,
we saw an increase with VCAP337 relative to the benchmark
in terms of its ability to target the cells.
We're seeing an increase in the amount of nuclei targeted.
Although we do note that we saw a little bit of a reduction
there in the expression in the quadriceps.
But in the heart, we were able to see an increase
in both of those metrics.
337 targeted a higher amount of nuclei in the heart
as well as increased this expression
about 10-fold relative to that of AAV9.
But I think the brain is actually where we see
our most exciting data.
So VCAP337 in the motor cortex of these primates
had upwards of 50% of nuclei being targeted
in the motor cortex.
And that led to about, that was measured
at about a 250-fold increase in AAV9 over,
or with VCAP337.
Now if we compare that to VCAPGEN2,
and I'll make the stipulation here
that VCAPGEN2 is data taken
from some historical data that we have,
and we presented years ago here at ASGCT.
But in terms of the number of nuclei targeted
and the amount of expression that we're seeing,
we're more than doubling in either case,
which we think is really exciting.
In the liver, we see the same thing that we saw on mouse
in that VCAP337 is largely reduced
and more similar to our CNS crossing capsids
than they are the muscle capsids.
I will make the disclaimer disclosure here
that the brain targeting mechanism of both 336 and 337
is in fact ALPL, that is the mechanism
by which they are getting into the BBB.
And we are continuing to evolve these
where we have next generation variants
beyond 336 and 337 that we're currently evaluating.
So to just give you a summary of what I described here,
we've developed muscle capsids with VCAP290,
has about a hundred fold increase in expression
over AAV9 in mouse skeletal muscle,
10 fold in cardiac muscle.
In primates, we're looking at 25 fold over AAV9
in the skeletal muscle and about 13 fold in heart.
At low doses, we can see that we're targeting
100% of muscle fibers in the mice.
And we've moved on to developing neuromuscular capsids
that we think have sort of the best of both worlds there
with VCAP336 and 337 and those are liver-detargeted
more similar to our brain capsids.
So with that, I wanna thank all my colleagues
at Voyager, current and former.
As you all know, these projects take a lot of brain,
a lot of muscle, so it's gonna give a shout out to them.
And with whatever time is remaining,
I'll be happy to take a question or two.
I think we have time for one good question.
I tell you, thanks, really exciting.
I was wondering, does 336 work in NHP
and does 337 work in mice?
We did not test them in the other species.
So I just can't say for certain.
I think to some degree they both would
work in the other species, but to what degree
I just can't say because we didn't do that experiment.
Moving forward, the next generation of variants
that we are evaluating, we're same capsid, both animals.
Thanks.
Thank you, Tyler.
Our next speaker is Nolan Graham from UC San Diego.
He'll be talking about receptor-guided
avetropism engineering via MATCH.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Hello everyone, my name's Nolan Graham.
I'm a PhD student in the lab of Dr. Prashant Mali
at UC San Diego and today I'll be talking about my research,
which is titled receptor-guided avetropism engineering
via MATCH.
So several of the main issues with AV gene therapy,
including high cost and toxicity,
stand to be overcome through the development
of more specific, efficient vectors.
Classically, these are identified
through large-scale screens, which are resource-intensive
and generally limited by the intolerance of the AAV capsid
to larger peptide insertions.
So previously, we've incorporated unnatural amino acids
and peptide tags into the AAV capsid.
And based on this, we developed the MATCH system,
which stands for modulation of AAV tropism
through conjugation to homing proteins.
Specifically, we wanted to redirect the tropism
of a couple of different AAVs to desired targets
by conjugating, targeting ligands to the capsid
via spy tags by catcher chemistry.
So to start, we went into AAV DJ and inserted a spy tag
into one of the protruding loop regions on the VP.
This was flanked by flexible GS linkers,
and then we incorporated this
into a fully spy tag containing capsid.
These capsids were reacted overnight
at room temperature with spy catcher.
And upon doing so, we saw a shift in the size of the VP
as a result of that covalent spy catcher attachment.
We took these to TEM to ensure
that we were still forming fully formed capsids.
And then upon spy catcher binding,
they maintained their integrity
with a slight topology change.
And upon going to DLS, we saw that there was a slight shift
in the mean diameter of these capsids.
So we wanted to preempt an issue at this point
that we foresaw where for covering the entire AAV capsid
with spy catcher, we wouldn't be allowing the binding
of secondary receptors such as AAVR,
which are required for the AAV
to effectively transduce and produce.
So to do this, we put together a panel of mosaic AAVs
with various ratios of AAV DJ to AAV spy tag
with many of them primarily composed of AAV DJ.
In hella cells, when we transduced in vitro,
we saw that the fully spy tag containing capsids
lost nearly all of the transduction ability
that native AAV DJ has.
And this is likely due to the insertion of the spy tag peptide
immediately in the heparin sulfate proteoglycan binding domain
of AAV DJ.
Interestingly, in the mosaic capsids,
we also saw a drop in transduction ability
upon spy catcher binding,
which is likely due to that steric occlusion
of binding sites that I mentioned before.
So we took our five to one and 11 to one mosaic capsids
and decided to start targeting.
So first we went into resting PBMCs,
which are classically a challenging target
for AAV transduction,
and attached either a CD3 or CD28 SCFEs
to the outside of the capsid.
And saw that the CD3 targeting SCFEs,
particularly the SCFE1,
were able to transduce the sizable portion
of the resting PBMCs without prior activation.
We also wanted to go for the brain
and to do so attached a murine transferrin receptor binding
SCFE to the outside of the capsid
and injected these retroorbitally in mice.
And saw that decorated capsids were able to transduce
the brain much more effectively than AAV DJ by itself.
So we wanted to bring this into a more popular
wild type AAV to be more therapeutically relevant.
And to do so, we decided to make match AAV9.
AAV9 is a wild type AAV that's already used
to target the CNS with engineered capsids.
And it uses a different primary receptor from AAV DJ
in that it uses galactose to bind
as opposed to upper and sulfate proteoglycan.
So to do so, we inserted our spot tag
into both loop one and loop two,
which are protruding loop regions on the VP,
and flank these by either 1X or 2X flexible linkers.
And upon forming full capsids with these spot tag
containing VP's, we saw that both L1 and L2,
loop 2X contained, were able to readily bind spot catching.
Additionally, when we incorporated these
into mosaic AAVs at a ratio of 11 to one,
they produced capsids with titers similar
to that of wild type AAV9.
So we went back to our T cell targeting
and used our CD3 SEFE1 and saw that upon transduction,
we were able to transduce over 50%
of the resting PBMC population.
Additionally, when we went to murine transferrin,
we were able to gain transduction ability
of the brain almost a hundredfold higher
than native AAV9.
Based on this success, we wanted to bring this
into a more therapeutically relevant space
using human transferrin receptor targeting.
And to do so, we put together a panel
from the literature of SEFE's that are targeting
human transferrin receptor, and used HEC cells
that had either been received a safe harbor AAVS1 locust
knockout or a transferrin receptor knockout
via Linty CRISPR, and saw in our AAVS1 knockout cells
that we were able to transduce these cells
much more efficiently than AAV9,
and also with efficacy comparable to that of BIHDFR1,
which is this recently engineered
human transferrin targeting AAV.
This improvement was attenuated in the cells
that received a transferrin receptor knockout,
supporting the concept that we're using
the transferrin receptor to do transduce.
So we took this in vivo with SEFE9 and SEFE12,
and used mice that express the apical domain
of the human transferrin receptor,
as opposed to the murine, and saw
that particularly SEFE12 yielded DNA-level and mRNA-level
transduction comparable to that of BIHDFR1.
We looked at the protein level next, using IHC,
and saw that we were getting brain-wide distribution
of our transgene, again comparable to that of BIHDFR1.
So this was pretty promising, but before we proceeded,
we wanted to ensure that this was more applicable
for many other labs.
So to do so, up until this point,
everything had been produced, either separately
with separate protein production from AAV production
as a kind of modular system, where you could retarget AAVs.
The same AAV to different targets,
depending on what you conjugate.
But at this point, we wanted to ensure
that we could make everything together
in a triple-transfection style approach.
So we have our standard triple-transfection plasmids,
which I'm sure many of you are familiar with.
And this also includes our spy tag rep cap,
which we've used up until this point in the mosaics,
and then also our spy catcher ligand.
So when we did this with the CD3 targeting SEFE,
we got titers, similar to the wild type AAV9, once again.
And when we took this in vitro, with our L1 and L2,
5 to 1 and 11 to 1 mosaics, we were
able to transduce a large portion of the T-cell population,
or PVMC population.
So in conclusion, the match AAV platform
overcomes a major challenge in the AAV engineering
by allowing us to put full-size proteins on the outside
of the AAV.
Through a series of small-scale binder screens,
we identified T-cell and brain-cell targeting motifs
that were pulled straight from the literature.
And one of these in CD3 targeted vectors,
we're able to transduce a majority of the PVMC population,
while MTFR1 and HDFR1 targeted vectors
transduce the brain effectively with much higher
transduction ability than AAV9 and comparable transduction
to that of popular engineered AAVs.
And finally, the mix and match vector productions
enabled one-pot generation of these targeted vectors
in a method that many labs will be familiar with using
the standard triple-transfection protocols.
So with that, I'd like to thank my mentor, Dr. Mali,
as well as my other co-authors in bold,
and as well as the rest of the lab.
This work has recently been accepted for publication,
so be sure to follow up.
Thank you.
Thanks, Nolan.
The floor is open for questions.
Is there any?
Very quick questions.
Do you have the characterization of your...
It's called match AAV.
Yes, how many copies of the antibody
decorated of your AAV?
So we're not able to directly quantify that yet.
Like how many SCFEs per AAV.
However, based on the kind of stochastic nature
of AAV assembly, we hope that it's relatively
similar to what we transfect at.
How about the full partial analytics?
Like, do you see a lot of full vector genome
being packaged with your novel AAV?
We haven't looked at that yet, but that's a great question.
Thank you.
That's really cool work.
So I was curious, was there a difference in the amount
of spy catcher that conjugated when you did it in vitro
as opposed to when you did it in the cell?
Transduction in vitro versus transduction in the cell?
No, the amount of spy catcher that
bound to the spy tag virus when you did it in vitro
as opposed to when you assembled it within the cell.
Oh, yes.
So we use a large excess, massive excess,
for all the conjugation reactions in vitro.
But when we transfect, it's about a quarter.
There's 100-fold excess of protein
when we do it outside the cell.
But in the cell, we just transfect at a certain ratio,
which is about a quarter of the total DNA transfected.
OK, and the second question was, so you use spy catcher 3,
but you use spy tag 1.
Is there a reason you didn't use spy tag 3?
Yes, so spy tag 3 is a little bit longer than spy tag 1.
So spy tag 1 is only 13 amino acids.
And based on the cross reactivity of spy catcher 3
and spy tag 1, we elected to ensure that our AVs would
package using a smaller peptide insertion.
OK, and the last question is, so when
you did your different ratios, your 11 is to 1,
is that just based on bulk ratios of how you estimated
how many spy tags on each capsid?
Yeah, so we transfect these plasmids
at a molar ratio of 11 to 1 or 5 to 1.
So yeah, the fact that they package similarly
indicates that hopefully they will be at that appropriate
ratio upon assembly.
Thank you.
Great, if there are no further questions, thank you, Nolan.
Our next speaker is Kyle Jue.
I'm waiting for his slides to come up.
There you go.
He'll be talking about ACE502, an AAV5 derived capsid
engineered by InVivo Directed Evolution
for robust CNS transduction and liver detargeting.
Take it away.
OK, thank you so much for your introduction.
So before I start, I want to give thanks
to the organized committee for having
me this great opportunity to share our exciting data on ACE502,
which is the AAV5 derived capsid engineered for CNS,
the robust CNS transduction, and at the same time
the liver detargeting.
So my name is Kyle Jue.
I'm the AAV Capsid Engineering Lead at Amiluid Solution
and also serve as a faculty member at Ewha Women's
University in Kerbya.
Let me briefly introduce our company, the Amiluid Solution.
So you may guess what we are doing from the name.
So Amiluid Solution is just the science-driven biotech,
mainly focused on developing many different disease
modifying kind of the therapies, especially
for Alzheimer's disease.
So basically, we have three different core interconnected
programs, mainly we are focusing on the brain
tropic, AB-based gene therapy kind of approach and platform.
And most of you are working for many different, just
a restoration of clear homeostasis for Alzheimer's
disease treatment.
Also, we are developing some of the diagnostics
for the Alzheimer's as well, too.
So ACE502 is served as a foundational gene delivery
vehicle for our therapeutic programs.
We are mainly working on the Capsid Engineering.
So this is how we discover that these noble caps of the ACE502.
Basically, we are starting from the AB-5 and engineer
two different variable regions at the Capsid
at the same time, variable region four and region eight,
and by substituting the amino acid sequences
by using the random peptide display.
After that, we're using the sequential crucifixes
in vivo screening in order to reduce
the risk of the single model, the selection bias,
and then to make sure that it's a functional
transduction in the brain.
So we just, once more, just pursue the mRNA-based screening
and the evaluation of the late Capsid variants
in non-human primates by using the DNA bar coding.
And after that, the most important question
is a protein-level expression.
So we are just selected the best single, the Capsid,
ACE502, by the individual protein level
head-to-head evaluation and validation
compared to many of the benchmark of capsids.
So based on the sequential, the mouse
to non-human primate in vivo screening,
so we were able to progressively enrich
many different CNS tropic capsid variants
over the AB5 wild time.
So as you can see that AB, ACE502 and 501,
located in a very high fold,
kind of increasing the enrichment
in the non-human primates.
And also, amino acid preference, the HIMMAP,
showing that they conserve the pattern
of the sequences and two different,
the burial region of the capsid of AB5.
So across the species, we have just enrichment
for that many different variants.
And if you're looking a little more close
into our in vivo kind of screening strategy,
so we're starting from the much bigger
and larger kind of volume of the library,
which is 10 to the seven variants.
And after the two round of the mouse in vivo screening,
and then we just selected the 10,000 variants,
which is successfully the transduced mouse brain
and synthesized and then we inject
into the non-human primate is the cynomogous macaque.
And then we further screened them out
by using your selection criteria,
which is the CNS tissue enrichment score,
and also at the same time it's a liberty targeting score,
which is the upper right kind of the corner of the box,
the where we identified our desired variants
that we are looking for.
And based on that, this kind of the in vivo screening,
so we were able to identify top performing 28 capsis.
And then we once again, we just do a mRNA based evaluation
for the lid capsis for make sure
that is a functional transduction.
So as you can see the ACE502 and 501 could achieve
around the 70 fold increase in enrichment
compared to the wild type of AV5 and AV9 as well
in the non-human primates.
And also we co-injected published,
kind of two of the published well-known benchmark capsis
and compared to our capsid.
So interestingly, we can have even higher transduction
compared to those benchmark, the competitor capsis.
And this heat map showing that our ACE502 and 501
could transduce successfully in a different region
of the brain, including the frontal cortex and motor cortex
and deeper brain region, which is hippocampus
and sub-sensional nigra and so on.
And then we see that in peripheral tissues,
including the liver and heart, including the TRG as well.
So ACE501 and 502 is a significantly reduced signal
compared to wild type of the AV5 and AV9
in mRNA level of expression.
So this is comprehensive mRNA expression profile
compares ACE502 against all benchmark capsid
included wild types.
So dark blue is ACE501 and light blue is ACE502.
So you can see that it's consistently maintained
a higher transduction in all the region of the brain
compared to the AV9 wild type from the celibate lung
and cortex and deep brain like a hippocampus
and sub-sensional nigra and thalamus and brain stem
and including the spinal cord as well.
And this baseline is AV5 and then you can see
that green dot is AV9 wild type.
And then you can see the peripheral tissue,
especially in liver, ACE501 and 502,
significantly reduced that mRNA expression
compared to the wild type AV9.
So we believe that it has a feature of the safety
kind of profile of the liver de-targeting.
So we move on to the most important question,
is what about the protein level expression?
So we have two different animals for each group
and then we have a total seven groups
of the non-human primate study,
including the non-injection.
So ACE501 and 502 and we include
the two different kind of competitor capsid as well,
which is well known, and AV5, AV9 wild type.
So we just delivered the GFP on their CNB promoter
and the IV injection at the dose of 1-E13
vector genome per kilogram.
So as you can see that ACE502 at this dose
can achieve around the 100 fold increase
in the whole brain as a protein level expression
compared to the wild type of AV5 and AV9.
And we just increased that higher,
the dose of the ACE502,
which is three times the higher of the lower dose.
So as you can see that around the 3.9 fold increase
in a protein level expression in the whole brain,
which indicating that the ACE502 could translate the cell
in a dose-dependent manner.
And more greater thing is in the liver.
So we can deliver at the dose of the 1-E13.
So you can see that around the ACE502 can reduce
that the liver accumulation by 99%.
And greater thing is when we just deliver
that's a higher dose of ACE502,
which is three times the higher,
but still we can maintain the 99% of the targeting
compared to the wild type of the AV5
and also the AV9 as well too.
So as you can see, so Western blood is confirmed
that our ACE502 can transduce in many different regions
of the brain in those different manner.
So kind of cortex region and deep brain region
in hippocampus and sub-sensional nigra.
So we can see pretty much of the signal
compared to the many different benchmark capsids.
And in the liver, you can see that's a very minimized
and reduced signal compared to our CNS tissues.
So this fluorescent imaging is kind of provide visually
kind of compelling a demonstration of ACE502
in greater transduction in the whole brain
in a non-human primate.
So compared to AV5 wild type,
AV9 has a slightly brighter signal of the whole brain.
And then very similar level of expression
of the published capsid, two of those capsid at this dose.
And then at the same dose in ACE502,
you can see the brighter signal in the whole brain
in a non-human primate.
And then even higher and brighter signal at higher dose,
which is three times the higher compared to the lower one.
And we can see there is a very robust CNS
and whole brain expression too.
So we'll go a little more detail into the,
look into the closely into the vision of each brain region.
So you can see, so we're just sustaining with that,
the neuron cells with the map to staining.
And also we are doing in situ hybridization
with the GFP with the red color.
So in a cortex region,
you can see pretty much of the GFP expression
of overlap with the neuron cells.
And also in, especially for the deep brain region,
which is a substantial nigra and thalamus,
we could observe that pretty much a bright signal
of the protein expression of ACE502.
So before they confirm with that,
the immunohistochemistry to ask it to make sure
that this is not exacerbated any fluorescent imaging.
So very, very similar kind of result to be observed.
And then it's broadly displaying the whole brain.
And then the next question is how much percentage
of the neuron cells can be transduced by ACE502?
So it's depends on the region of the brain,
from that the 20 to 50% of the neuron cells
can be transduced by that, the ACE502.
And interesting as compared to the transduction
of the wild type AB5, it can be enhanced
at around that 180 fold increase,
especially for substantial nigra and thalamus,
which is that kind of deep brain region.
So next one is how we just had to have the kind of evaluation
for the liver.
So as you can see that AB5 is pretty much
a chip expression all over the liver.
And it's very similar to the pattern of the result
in AB9 as well.
And a little bit reduced signal in a two different capsid,
the competitor capsid as well.
For ACE502 at the same dose,
we can achieve around 99% of the detargeting
compared to the wild type,
which is a very kind of comparing data that we have.
So currently we're working for the identified receptor.
Hopefully it's a find that some new receptor,
you could be on another one transporting anything else.
So based on that, we're gonna get the result very soon.
So based on that, we can just pursue the original design
for next generation of ACE502.
So this is a wrap up, I'm in the slide for the,
take a message.
So basically whole brain of the non-human primate,
we could achieve around 100 fold increase
at the specific dose and CNS transduction.
At the same time, we can lower that 99% of that
liver detargeting and liver accumulations.
So we believe that ACE502 could be promising
kind of capsid for robust CNS transduction
at the same time that liver detargeting.
So that's what we are prepared today.
So thank you so much for your attention.
Some I'm happy to answer any question you may have.
Thank you.
Thanks, Guy.
The floor's open.
Did you look at the vector genome distribution?
That's a good question.
We are just working on that.
So basically we will just see then hold that,
the western blood and different, the fluorescent imaging,
but we wanna quantify that how much kind of the vector genome
can deliver to the each cells of the,
in the each different region of the brain.
Yeah, especially in the liver because AV5 notoriously
doesn't transduce the liver well.
Yeah, that's a good, yeah.
So we are gonna work on that, yeah.
Any other questions from the floor?
Maybe I'll take this opportunity to ask the question myself.
Interested in know the thinking behind the choice
of the base capsid, why AV5 and sort of a follow up question
to that, these published capsid that you benchmark with,
are they also AV5 based?
And now, the reason why we chose AV5 is,
yeah, it's well known as a pre-existing immunity
is much lower compared to the AV9.
Even though it's AV9 known to the,
going to the better way to the brain.
That's why we're starting from that
and then relatively lower accumulation to the liver
compared to the AV9.
And all benchmark capsid is AV9 derived capsids.
Perfect, thank you guys.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Zenhua Wu, yeah, perfect.
He'll be talking to us, he's from Exagenesis.
He'll be talking to us about transferrin' receptor,
targeting AV, achieved superior and broad CNS transduction
in multiple species after intravenous administration.
Zenhua, when you're ready.
Thank you very much, thanks for the invitation
for this great opportunity to present here at ASGCT.
So this is our forward-looking statement.
Our Exagenesis bio is AV-based gene therapy company
focused on CNS and ophthalmology field.
As the previous two talks mentioned a lot
about the random library screening,
there are many different ways to screen novel libraries
and novel AV capsid for seeing as penetrating capsid.
The random library is really great.
At one time you can screen up to one million virus at one time.
However, there is also caveats.
Whenever there is hits you really don't know the mechanism,
you really don't know which receptor binds to.
So with that we really think about
what we can screen seeing as penetrating capsid differently.
And this is the new system that we generated.
We call the receptor targeting AV engineering system.
In this particular system what we do is that we come up
with a transferrin' receptor binding library
as a peptide library.
And with that transferring, preferring a library,
we insert into AV and then we screen directly
into directly in monkey and see whether with a no-magnetism
whether you have a better chance
to find a CNS penetrating capsid.
And we have a lot of, we use heavily on AI
in terms of generating the peptide library.
I'm gonna go through the details of the AI process.
At the end we found a very good seeing as penetrating capsid
we called RTAV-001.
And when we got the capsid we really test the affinity
against the human, TFR monkey, TFR,
and also mouse TFR to see whether there is any difference.
And the end result is the affinity
against all three species are very, very similar.
So we're very encouraged by that
because we know if that particular capsid works in mouse,
it should work in monkey and also should work in human.
And also we later on did a TEM study to see
whether we can figure out the binding pocket
of the particular receptor and as shown here actually
we did figure out the binding pocket is actually,
first is allosteric.
It does not hinder the detection of transferring,
binding to transfer receptor.
And also we figured out the modern kind of magnets
why this particular association really render
the specificity towards the TFR receptor.
So we know exactly where it binds to,
we know exactly how it binds to transfer receptor.
And we put this particular capsid into mice.
As you can see here from the top left
is the GDNA results.
As we can see, we see 30 to 60% fold increase
in terms of, I'm sorry, 20 to 30% increase on the GDNA.
And on the top right is the MRI expression.
And we see up to 60 fold increase
in terms of the RNA expression.
At the same time, we also took a look of the GDNA distribution
and MRI expression in the liver and in the muscle
because we have some concerns that TFR targeting AV
might increase the distribution to the muscle and the liver.
As a matter of fact, we see about a three to four fold
decrease in the liver.
And muscle wise, we see exactly same distribution expression
compared to AV9.
Of course, we put into mice and we did the,
you know, histochemically staining.
And as we can see on the top panels are the AV9 staining.
There's not much of green trenching expression.
On the bottom is the RT-AV-001 as really transduced
very efficiently across the brain regions.
And we quantified about 50 to 80% of the neurons
are actually transduced.
At the same time, we also take a look of the transduction
of marker-clear and astrocytes.
And indeed, the RT-AV-001 can transduce
some astrocytes and marker-clear.
But in terms of the percentage, it's less than 5%,
much less compared to neuronal transduction.
Maybe because the RT-AV-001 targeting TFR
and the neuronal has TFR receptor
on the surface of their neurons.
And also we really take a look of the RT-AV expression,
whether that induce any histological change to the brain.
And based on this pathological findings studies,
we really don't see much change in the neuron.
So prove that this is safe in mouse.
Next is we really put that RT-AV into monkey studies.
And because of there are a lot of reports
in terms of if you switch monkey species,
the AV transduction will change.
So we use actually two species, monkey,
sandal monkey, and also rhesus monkey.
In these studies, we call those RT-AV-001 with AV-9
at the same time.
Each of them is a 4E13 VG per kg dose.
And when we combine them,
both capsules contains the same transgene,
but with different tags.
So at the end of the study,
we can really use IHC to study
which capsules are expressing at what level.
And of course, we take all the organs and all the tissues
and do all the DNA mRNA and the protein expression study.
This is the results from rhesus monkey.
Again, on the top left is GDNA.
In the middle is mRNA and on the right
is the GDNA and mRNA results in all the other tissues.
Very, very striking difference between AV-9 versus RT-AV-001.
And for mRNA expression-wise,
we reach up to 250 fold increase
across all the brain regions very consistently,
including the spinal cord.
And when we look at the distribution across other brain,
other tissues, only liver, again,
had a three to four fold decrease in distribution
and mRNA expression and across all other regions,
including spleen, including muscle,
including other organs are almost the same.
So has slightly leverage targeting property for RT-AV-001.
And again, this is immunohistochemistraining.
As you can see, this is really
across all the brain regions, RT-AV-001.
It was very factly transducing neuronal cells
compared to AV-9, almost no positive staining was observed.
And even including the spinal cord,
up to 70% of the spinal neuronal,
motor neurons are really transduced.
And then when we quantify the neuronal transduction,
about 30% to 70% of neurons are transduced
depending on different brain regions, highly efficient.
This is the signal monkey study and the same results.
So I'm not gonna go through the details.
And this is staining exactly,
look like similar to resists monkey.
We also took a look of the potential liability
for anemia, liability for this particular capsule.
Because as we know, transferring targeting
can cause anemia and cause reticular sites reduction
and real plus cells reduction.
As you can see from here,
really don't see any concerns of anemia.
And at the same time, because of this AV-9 plus RT-AV,
total dose is AE13BGPKG.
So as expected, we see some AST and AOT transient increase,
but this is really expected.
So this is really very, very tolerated
the capsule in monkey.
We also took a look of the histopathology
of this particular capsule in monkey brains
and also liver as well.
And we really don't see any concerns
in terms of morphological changes
after RT-AV-001 dosing.
And the same thing for resists monkey as well.
Again, we now put into the capsidine
to transfer receptor, human transfer,
knocking animals as you can see from here.
This is highly efficient in human TFR knocking animals
as well compared to white type.
The transduction rate is almost,
look like almost the same.
So we know that that also works on human TFR,
even in the TFR knocking transnet animal.
And also we put that into human cells, right?
We use the HEK cells, which express TFR highly
and on the top is the AV-9 transaction
on in vitro on HEK.
And really nothing really transdues
or very low transduction rate on HEK at that MOI.
But at same MOI, we can see really tremendous
internalization of the capsidine in the HEK cells.
So again, this is a second sort of indirect proof
that it might work in human,
at least it binds to human receptors.
And we talk a look of the manufacturability
of this particular capsidine and compared to AV-9,
the manufacturability is really very similar,
including the upstream yield
and also the upstream full and empty capsid,
very similar to AV-9.
So we think this is highly manufacturable as well.
So next thing is we really want to put this RTAV-01
into human testing.
And the first indication we choose is SMA.
So we did this particular study in SMA-transient animals.
As you know, SMA-transient animals,
if you don't rescue a majority of the mice
were died before three weeks on the right,
as you can see the survivor curve.
The black line is the animals
that without any treatment or with the vehicle treatment,
the animal dies very quickly.
And two red lines are AV-9 version
of the vectors expressing SMA-N1 protein.
And they can rescue the survivor really dramatically,
especially at two E, 14 VG per kg dose,
highly efficient, can push the survivor curve
all the way to 120 days.
But even at a four times lower dose
with RTAV-001, the survivor curve rescue effect
is really, really second event compared to
the AV-9 version of the vector.
So we believe it would really work in the SMA model.
And on the left is the tissue distribution data.
Even at a 10 times lower dose,
RTAV-001 can have much higher tissue distribution
in all brain regions.
Again, indicating the RTAV-001
is a really good capsular for the SMA treatment.
And currently the capsular is under the development,
R&D and delving development.
And we plan to put this particular product
into human testing, hopefully by the end of the year
or beginning of next year.
And this is the conclusion.
Basically RTAV is seeing as penetrating AV
with a really different mechanism
and very known mechanism toward BBB.
And we believe this particular capsular
is highly manufacturable and we are gonna go
on the end of the studies and put that into human testing.
And thank you very much.
I would address any questions you might have.
Thank you.
Floor's open.
Hi, that was a great talk.
I was wondering if you looked at the immunogenicity profile
of the capsid in non-human primates
if it was comparable to AV9 or not.
Very good question, we did.
And we believe this is very similar to AV9.
Great talk.
So you only...
Can we take a question from the other side?
We'll keep switching.
Okay.
Hi, great talk. How did you land on the, I think, nanobody that was inserted into AV9
for RTAV1? I think you just glossed over that very briefly, the screening method, I guess.
Yeah, the library, the TFR binding library, we generate, it consists of really different
binding peptides, long, short, including nanobody candidates. So there's a really variety of
candidates in that particular library. And among this library, we found this particular AV
capsid, RTAV01. And how is this library designed? As I mentioned, we use a lot of AI tools. Again,
there's many different steps. We generate the scaffold first, then filling the sequences.
Really, we're trying to predict the binding affinity between the binding peptides versus
our transfer receptor. Thank you. Great talk. So you insert the affinity peptide in the well
type AV9 on one loop, right? Correct. Yeah, so you'll keep the other side unchanged. You don't do
the mutation like reducing the lever targeting? No, we didn't do lever targeting mutation. There's
only one insertion of the TFR binding peptides. Okay, how that, you know, you only insert TFR affinity
peptide and it can, you know, enhance BBB crossing. But when the AV in crossing to the brim, how can
they mainly targeting the neural cells? Yeah, as I mentioned, the neuronal, because neurons have a
high expression of the transfer receptor. And then maybe that's the reason neural has better
uptake of the RT-AV001 compared to astrocytes and microglia cells. Yeah, another one, one
explanation. And microglias and astrocytes are highly turnover cells. And within a month, maybe
some of the instructions are gone already. Okay, another small question. How long is the peptide?
How long is the peptide? Yeah, we have various of different peptides. And in this case, the
peptide is really big. It's not seven or 10 or 12 amino acids, a really long peptide. And the
fundamental reason is because smaller peptides will have smaller interface with the transfer
receptor. And any change on the receptor, for example, species change, we're may disrupt this
binding. That's why we're looking for a bigger binding pocket. And in our TAEM study, we finally
mapped out the binding sequence or binding aptop of that interaction. And the binding sequence, the
sequence is 100% conserved in mouse, in monkey and in human. That's probably why we saw similar
affinity in mouse and monkey and human receptors. Okay, thank you. Thanks. I apologize. We are a
little bit out of time. I encourage the questioners to ask the question after the session to the
speakers. So let's maybe thank Zandua for her speech. Thank you very much.
Our next speaker is Angela-Enrica Arajo. She's going to be talking about the future of CAR-T
cells towards the in vivo generation of stable CAR-T T cells with T cell tropic adenos associated
viral vectors. Thank you for your kind introduction. And thank you for the to the organization to give
me the opportunity today to present my work about in vivo generation of CAR-T cells using AV
vectors. So T cell-based gene and cell therapies are mainly focused on the use of CAR-T in the
ecological field. But as we know, the field is currently expanding for the treatment of
autoimmune disease, infection disease. And of course, we can also modify T cells for the treatment
of immunodeficiencies. And currently, the genetic modification of T cells is based
on the ex vivo modification, usually using, sorry, integrative vector, like lentiviral
vector or nucleofaction. But this type of process are time consuming, very costly, depend on the
presence of specialized center. And this, of course, can decrease the accessibility of the type
of therapies. And modifying in vivo, the T cells directly on the bloodstream of the patient can
help reduce some of this problematic. And one of the vector that's been proposed for this type of
therapies are AVs. And as is the focus of today's section, AV can modify to retargeting. And in my
project, we started with AV2 peptide supply library with a seven amino acid peptide insertion
in the second I speak of AV2. And this library was then selected in vivo in non-human primates
and we isolate different T cells populations, in particular in focus on naive and memory cells
of the CD4 and CD8 T cells. And from the NGS analysis of the DNA isolated from these cells,
we identified 21 candidates that were particularly enriched on the T cells. And we can see the
enrichment for our 21 candidates in the different population. And we can see as our very strict
condition for the first selection rounds allow us to directly select our candidate after just one
selection round in vivo. In generally, the variants were enriched in all the different
populations, but some show a particular preference for one of more T cells population,
like for example, variant six, just in the CD4 cells memory cells,
or variant nine in the CD4, different CD4 populations. And to give you our overview,
how we test and confirm the trophism of our 21 candidates, we first test them in vitro,
in human T cells, and this allows us already to reduce the number of candidates from 21 to 12
that were equipped with a GFP with a unique barcode for each of them. And we saw then test
them in pool in human blood for both efficiency and specificity. And we perform also a view
distribution in vivo in like six mice. And for this experiment, we were able to identify
two final candidates that we renamed NG3 and NG6, one particularly efficient and one
particularly specific for the transduction of human T cells. So now let's go back and see why
we choose these two candidates. And we can see here our test on human primary T cells in vitro,
where a different GOI, so vector genome per cells, our variants outperform AV2 wild type
in both CD4 and CD8 population that we can see in blue and in green. And the results were even
more impressive when we compare these two variants with AV2 and AV6, that is considered the gold
standard in the human blood. So after transduction in the human blood, we isolate also the T cells
and the T cells population to look for both efficiency and selectivity. And of course we can
see here in the T cells CDNA that AV6 is doing the job quite well as expected. But if we compare
the expression at the CDNA level with the GNA level amount, we can see that our variants are
much more effective in T cells, in aspraxine and on T cells than AV6. And if we go even forward and
look at the ratio between the expression on the T cells to the non-T cells population, we can see
here that AV6 is not specific at all, while our H3 and in particular the H6
show up very clearly selectivity for the T cells population. And this was confirmed when also with
flow cytometry for GXP expression, when we test the variants separately in human blood. And we
can see here that AV6 in black clearly has a better expression efficiency in non-T cells when it's
inside our perform by our variants in the T cells population. In the black six mine,
our view distribution, we can see here in light green and dark green that two of our vectors show
a particular enrichment in the T cells and CD4 and CD8 population, isolate for both the spleen
and the blood of the mice. And H3, it's one of these two candidates and this confirmed that our
variants, it's able to target in T cells in different species. And the other variants,
variant two, share a very close similar peptide insertion that will also conform the
strongness of our selection. But now let's go back to the in vivo generation of CAR T cells.
And for this AV present a limitation, they don't, they lack an integrase, so they remain
and usually epizomal form inside the cells. But this will mean that we'll lose car expression
or every cell division in the activated cells. And has been sure of course that for CAR T cells
therapies, the persistence in vivos of the CAR T, it's linked to the success of this type of
therapies. So what is our solution? And our solution is using our selected vectors in a dual
AV platform where one vector will encode for the transposase and the other will encode for the car
in a transposable element. And the idea is that when both vector enter the T cells, the car will
be integrated and we label a stable CAR T cells. And transposase, transposone approach, it's already
in clinical trials using nucleofection, so ex vivo production of CAR T cells. And our idea is to
combine this approach with our AV vectors to a stable in vivo CAR T cells generation. And we
already show and test this approach in vitro, in primary T cells. And we can see in the central
figure that with us two different car constructs and we were able to obtain more than 20% of
CD19 positive CAR T cells with a dual vector approach or more than 10% of our raw one CAR T
cells. And on the figure on the left, we can see that this, the car expression was stable
maintained for more than four weeks in the presence of the transposase vector when in its absence
the expression of the CAR T cells declined over time. Also the CAR T cells produced with our
angiotree vector that we can see red, where at the same level or outperform the nucleofection
produce CAR T, so the current standard method using this technology. And we can see in the last
picture on the right, also the AV produced CAR T cells show a better viability to the one
produce using the standard nucleofection method. And maybe you notice that we also test AV6
as comparison and it was still performing our variants for the percentage of the CAR T cells
produced. However, when we test the CAR T for cytotoxicity assay for specifics cell killing in
both CD19 or raw one positive T cells, our angiotree CAR T show similar or even better
killing activity in the AV6 produced one. And in both cases they were outperforming the nucleofection
produced ones. So I'm already to my summary, so I hope that I show you today that we have identified
two AV candidates that have increased production efficiency and trophies for T cells both in
vitro in X vivo and in vivo and that a dual AV approach can be used with these candidates to
have in vivo stable CAR T generation. And now after our testing we are now moving forwards with
the in vivo evaluation of our approach in humanized mice and we are really hopeful that our system
can become an easily adaptable platform for different CAR concerts and this can help reduce
the cost and making CAR T scalable off the shelf product that can increase their accessibility
in the world. And I want to finish my presentation thanking especially the CAR Tervik team that
is responsible between MHH in ANOVA and the University of Woosburg of this dual AV approach
and of course all my group in ANOVA and all our all our collaborators and my PI Ildegab Yuning
and I want to thank all of you for listening to me today and now I open to answer any question.
Floors open.
Thank you for the presentation. We're already struggling and making everything we can to decrease
the cost of making one AV. Here you're doubling the cost of the dose so I mean it's not the first
time I see it. It works for sure. But now we are more seeing trying approaches where if we're
using two vectors trying to use other type of vectors that maybe are decreasing the cost so
there's already examples of that in clinical such as VLP, EV, EDV, LNPs as well combined with the AV
or there's also I've seen people being able to reduce the size of the transposage or miniaturize
so everything fits into one AV. So I would suggest if you want really to go for affordability
and accessibility to the patient that you try to think about that strategy because this is not
going to solve it. It was a great talk. Yes thank you so much. It's an interesting point but just
to comment on this for now we are going at least what we saw for the in vitro results and what we
plan to test in vivo if it works. We are going to the same dose that people are testing in animals
for just one AV approach but like not integrative and for now it's working so we didn't have to
increase the dose but yeah of course it's a great point. Thank you. Yeah very nice work. I'm Wen
from VCU. I have two questions. The first one I guess you have some justification why you use AV2
for the library not AV6 because AV2 not strong enough to transduce T cell. Yeah it's true but AV6
it's very efficient when tested in vitro already in vivo it's really struggling to do the job even
more than AV2 because it's diluted and targeting the liver and for what we have saw at least it's
when we go already in the blood or in vivo in the mice our vet or it's able to do the job much
better. Last question in the mouse model maybe you have the point I missed that what's the
maximum efficiency for mouse T cell in vivo you can get in the mouse primary T cell so what's the
maximum transducing efficiency. Oh yeah for that experiment it was barcode so at the end the results
was obtained through the NGS reads and we compare the we're in a staging we compare the different
variants between them so we don't have a single capsid efficiency for the mouse model but we are
currently both in this project and other projects that were born from my capsid testing the
efficiency in mouse of the single variant so we'll be in my next talk. Thank you.
Excellent if there are no further questions thank you. Thank you.
Our next speaker is Samantha Howard from Alexion. She is going to be presenting
an AV capsid presenting a miniaturized anti-transferend receptor antibody enables
systemic CNSY distribution with minimal liver tropism and cross-species conservation.
Hi everyone my name is Samantha Howard I'm a senior scientist in biology in the genomic medicine
unit at Alexion AstraZeneca and we're based in Cambridge. I'm excited to be here today to share
with you some of our bio distribution data from evaluating a novel capsid that enables broad
CNS distribution and liberty targeting. Here's my disclosures. So just AAV is a novel
EVV punishment capsule that provides broad brain distribution and minimal liver expression.
It's been developed by JCR Pharmaceuticals and licensed to Alexion AstraZeneca. Just AAV crosses
the blood-brain barrier via transfer mediated transcytosis which is a clinically validated pathway
with other modalities including those that has been already in the clinic by JCR Pharmaceuticals.
So it's been designed to engage both somologous and human TFR which does enable
animal models for multiple preclinical studies and how it actually engages transfer
and receptor is it contains a miniaturized antibody that recognizes HTFR and just to orient
to you with the rest of the data in this deck payload that we use to evaluate bio distribution
has a neuronal specific promoter. So first we want to assess how the just AAV performs in
vitro and to do that we compare just AAV versus AAV9 and both contain the same payload. We're
able to see greater transduction with just AAV versus AAV9 in a human neuroblastoma cell line
and that was sustained across all the MOIs tested and also with the ability to see these
high transduction and RNA expression rates at these lower MOIs we felt this was really exciting
because just AAV can be a nice tool capsid for various in vitro workflows such as screening
or potency assays in manufacturing. So next we want to look at how this capsid performs in vivo
and so for these capsid selection studies what we did was evaluated the just AAV with the same
trans genes versus AAV9 in HTFR knock and mice in a line that was developed by JCR
and synomologous macaque. Both animals receive a single IV injection of the AAV and we're taken
out for a set endpoint with mice being just four weeks and synomologous macaques either four or
thirteen weeks. For evaluating and bio-distribution we paired both biochemistry and histological
analysis in particular having one hemisphere sent for the biochemistry workflow either micro
dissected in the mouse or tissue punches in the NHP and the other side for histology and linking
molecular and spatial bio-distribution readouts such as vector genome copies, RNA expression,
protein expression or histology looking at transitioning RNA scope with tissue hybridization
as well as new and immunohist chemistry to understand distribution in their own since we
are using a neuronal promoter. So now into the data. So on the left hand side we have data from the
HTFR knock and mice and what we did here was compare at a vehicle AAV9, PHV, a known mouse
BB penetrant capsid as well as just AAV at two different doses. What we were able to see was
significant increase in brain vector genome copies and transient RNA expression significantly
above AAV9 and in addition we also saw significant liberty targeting in the mouse
and then on the right hand side we have the data in the NHP and so again this was a single IV
injection with endpoints of four or thirteen weeks and comparing AAV9 versus suggest AAV
and the filled circles are the four-week endpoints, open circles are the
twelve, thirteen-week endpoints and so we're able to also see increased vector genome copies
and transient RNA across various brain regions at various levels but still significantly above AAV9
as well as significant liberty targeting about 213 fold less than AAV9 and this is also sustained
between the two different doses. So while the chemistry analysis does allow us to understand
the biotrimition and RNA DNA protein relationships we are still limited to the bulk expression
so we did want to pivot to including the spatial analysis to have a more thorough characterization
of biotrimition with the cell type of regional specificity. So here are some example images
from the different biotrimist studies in the mouse and the NHP so on the left hand side again
we have the mouse RNA scope staining and then the right hand side is the NHP and so you can see
that there is broad distribution definitely different patterns and intensities so we went
after going ahead and quantifying that in the next slide. So using a series of AI image analysis
we built different algorithms for each of the different brain regions that have the different
patterns of distribution and we're able to quantify the percentage of transient RNA expression
and then also paired that in subsequent slides looking at the new and positive cells to quantify
an estimated level of neuronal transduction. So you can see in the mouse there is significant
expression in some regions getting close to 100% at that dose 2 and then in the NHP you can also
see a dose dependent increase across the various doses with some regions also at the top doses
reaching closer to that 100%. But it's important to note too that we did see that just that the
just AV transduction in the mouse is about five fold greater than the NHP when matching at the same
dose. However what was nice to see is that the regional patterns are pretty conserved with
certain regions such as the ponsentalamus trending to be the highest expression in both the species.
So considering pathology is as we're all very familiar with here about 95% between the CINOS
TFR and human TFR we know that small sequence differences can make a difference in impacting
efficiency but still it's nice that just AV remains one of the few transfer and media
BB penetration capsids with translatability across both species which does enable various
preclinical workflows. So in conclusion I share with you that just AV is a novel
BB penetration capsid modified and developed by JCR Pharmaceuticals that contains miniaturized
anti-TFR antibody that provides broad brain distribution and liberty targeting. And just
AV recognizes both the synomologous macaque and the human TFR receptors which does enable
use of the multiple species in clinical studies. And in the cap selection study we did observe
the disputed neuronal transaction as well as spatial analysis does support this as well.
Also realize I didn't quite mention yet that we also did some of the pathology reviews and we
didn't see any TA associated findings so that was also very encouraging as well. So our ongoing
work includes these data sets to characterize bio-distribution in specific sub-neuronal populations
which will then support indication selection and enabling pre-IND packages. Thank you.
Sorry but I also acknowledge everyone.
Yeah really appreciate all the work. Let's take any questions.
Hi there nice talk so can you comment on the manufacturability of these these constructs?
Do you see any aggregation in your final product? Can you comment on the
homogeneity of your final product? Definitely there is some different nuances with novel
caps as always independent of you know what size of insert or type but we didn't see any of those
problems. Okay thank you. Very nice talk. Good job. So I've got a question for you.
When compared to just AV and AV9 how does targeting the labor ratio change?
So it's definitely lower in the with the just AAB. Is that your question? Yes. Yeah so we saw
liberty targeting. You have the numbers? Regulation relatively? Oh yeah it was it was in the deck.
Hi I'm curious if you've mentioned if you've measured the seroactivity of this capsid compared
to AV9? It's comparable. Thanks. So and I'm kind of hinted at this at the end but I'm curious if
the antibody targeting for the transfer and receptor also changes the nature of cell specificity
within the tissues where you didn't have a hundred percent transduction. Do you get any kind of
change in cell specificity that you would expect out of some of the serotypes or are you still looking
into that? Yeah we're still looking into that but as commented earlier we know that transfer and
receptor highly express on neurons and that could also be there could be some differences there as
well. Thanks. Hi great talk. I'm going to ask you the question I couldn't ask before to the
transfer and receptor the previous talk that is it seems to be a disconnect between the engagement
for transcytosis no I'm crossing the barrier and then transduction in other tissues that are known
to express the transfer receptor liver muscle is there a mechanistic understanding that you can
comment on to to understand this? Yeah I think you're getting at a really big question in the field
but I think there's some excellent work out there showing that affinity makes a big difference
so you know each even small sequence changes can make a big impact on affinity so I'm sure that
is a huge part of it. It's like a sweet spot that is better for transcytosis let's say but
but it keeps you away the other tissues that are bigger and may suck up. Exactly yeah and there could
also be you know different paths of expression and perhaps even different tissues of different
affinities that are needed to get into different regions so I think it's a big field of research
so thank you thank you. I have a question for you yeah since it's an antibody-based
sort of binding to TFR as I understand that can you comment maybe a little bit on the structural
aspects of this binding do you bind the same spot that that transparent binds these receptors or
do you bind away from it? The reason I'm asking is because obviously we know there are capsules that
bind Sinnoh and don't bind human or vice versa and I'm trying to understand if you sort of nail
down that that that sweet spot. Yeah I can't comment on like the exact area but it's conserved
between the species so it was taken into account. Okay there are no further questions in the room
thank you Samantha. We have the last speaker for the session Rebecca Winkler.
Rebecca is going to talk to us about the variable region one of AB9 capsid is a permissive
site for peptide insertion whenever you're ready Rebecca. Okay thank you all for coming today and
thank you for the opportunity to present our research so as he mentioned this is a more of a
proof-of-concept study looking at variable region one. No disclosures. For a quick review
the AAV capsid is a three-dimensional sphere made up of 60 subunits of in those the subunits are
one of three isoforms VP1, VP2, VP3 that would result from different start sites
in the the cap gene and then also coded for in the cap gene is the AAP protein which is not part of
the final capsid but it's involved in capsid assembly and that protein is interesting because
it's in a one-plus frame shift from the the viral proteins so I think like the jargon is a little
confusing because VP1, 2, 3 are viral proteins the VR1 through 9 are variable regions which are
different surface regions that would vary between serotypes and when people use like a peptide
library or something for capsid engineering typically they will insert the peptide either
into variable region eight or variable region four we instead decided to look at variable
region one to see if that was going to be a region that could be used for capsid engineering
so we're starting with an AV9 and then the so in the box on the left the sequences in blue
are the variable region and then the red is the peptide that we inserted and so like I said this is
a proof of concept study we used a flag tag peptide because it has a antibody that recognizes it
very well and it also has a enzyme that will digest it so we have two different binding
partners two different methods that we can use